mps are slated to return to the house of
commons today this is anti-vaccine
protesters converge on parliament hill
for a third straight day the
demonstrations brought the city to a
standstill over the weekend and
organizers say they're not leaving until
their demands are met so with more on
the situation and what's expected today
let's bring in our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson good morning mercedes
good morning how are you i am great
thanks for joining us this morning let's
talk about how things are shaping up in
ottawa this morning how might the
protest impact the parliamentary restart
well it's going to restart no matter
what the difficulty will be for some mps
who want to actually go to parliament
hill in person i went out before we sat
down to chat this morning and had a
little look around at what's happening
and i can tell you that what i last saw
was about seven blocks back from
parliament hill still pretty much
gridlocked on all of the main streets
going in there was one that had more
openings on it a street called elgin but
a lot of the ones that parliamentarians
use to go to work are blocked by trucks
that are either running or parked uh and
that has been the case since i first
started looking out uh early early this
morning while it was still dark now
there is a virtual parliament in session
so it won't actually stop any mps from
being able to do their jobs but they may
not be able to show up on parliament
hill and there's another question in
terms of security of how comfortable
people might feel trying to enter
parliament hill talking to some mps this
morning there was a warning from the
sergeant-at-arms he runs security late
last week that some members of this
protest group were saying they were
looking for mp's home addresses
so perhaps a few more will choose to
stay home i suspect several conservative
mps will still go this morning but it's
certainly whether you're an mp or just a
normal citizen here in ottawa has
completely snarled traffic for now the
fourth day in a row yeah there's really
no telling how long they plan to be
there they say they're not going to
leave until they
feel like they're being heard so what
are you hearing from protest organizers
and
what do they want exactly and do they
feel like
they're
making any
any
headway when it comes to being heard
well it doesn't appear that prime
minister justin trudeau has talked to
them aaron o'toole did prime minister
trudeau has actually moved to another
location over security concerns around
the protest coming in and i should say
that this has been a protest that has
had some extremist elements attached on
it was also very peaceful this weekend
while it was inconvenient um there
wasn't violence it was kind of like a
party atmosphere and people seemed to
just be blowing off steam after having
been inside with covid in terms of what
their demands are this seems to be
evolving and it's not consistent across
the group so it started with truckers
wanting the federal government to
reverse the vaccine mandate at the
border that is something that justin
trudeau does have the power to do
however he can't make joe biden change
the rules the president has the same
rule in place for truckers entering the
united states that then evolved into
getting rid of all vaccine mandates and
coveted restrictions many of which are
actually provincial governments and one
organizer patrick king who in the past
has been affiliated with far right
movements says that they're not leaving
until the liberal party is out of power
so as you can see this is a moving
target and it doesn't seem to be
consistent across the protesters with
what exactly they're looking for now in
terms of what happened over the weekend
we know there are some investigations
taking place what are you hearing from
police and
what does it look like when we're
talking about enforcement in the days to
come
i can tell you there's a lot of
frustration for people who live in
downtown ottawa because the noise has
been non-stop the honking is not just on
parliament hill it's for blocks and
blocks back
and it is going for hours and hours and
hours every day people can't drive into
or out of their homes they can't get
groceries
so there's certainly a sense of
frustration with the ottawa police by a
lot of residents who say they want them
to do more enforcement the police have
said they were prioritizing safety and
managing traffic they are now moving
into more of an enforcement posture it's
not clear really whether they're going
to forcibly clear protesters out at some
point uh the thought was sort of from
sources i was talking to let things go
over the weekend don't escalate things
maybe move in next week but with no sign
of this alleviating it's a big question
mark and it's costing a lot of money the
ottawa police are pegging this at eight
hundred thousand dollars a day now in
terms of what it is costing to police
this uh and of course as you saw there
was quite a bit of anger and outrage
over somebody dancing on the tomb of the
unknown soldier at the national war
memorial and the defacing of the terry
fox statue on parliament hill
most of the protest was peaceful but
some of those elements very disturbing
also seen confederate flags uh at least
two and a nazi flag as well so uh again
it's a very wide-ranging protest but
whatever the case it is still clogging
up the streets of ottawa and you're
gonna see more and more pressure i think
on the local government here in ottawa
to do something about that all right and
we know that you'll be keeping an eye on
that as well mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thanks so much